hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2011 spanish science fiction and
thriller movie called the skin i live in
the movie begins with a maid morelia
delivering meals and supplies to a
locked up girl vera in a mansion
through the intercom vera requests
marilia to bring her scissors and other
tools but marilia considers it
ridiculous
meanwhile at an event the owner of the
house robert legerd a renowned plastic
surgeon is giving a speech about the
importance of facial reconstruction
after the event he goes to his lab to
examine a blood sample he carried inside
a package
after the examination he goes to his
room and monitors vera through camera
footage then goes to her room to offer
her some opium
however she notices vera has fallen
unconscious and checks on her finding
scratches on her body he picks her up
and performs surgery in his lab to save
her commenting that her skin is very
soft vera tells him that she will kill
herself nevertheless but robert is
committed to making her skin as strong
as possible so she would not get
scratched burned or bitten by mosquitoes
he calls his invention gal after his
late wife's name and presents it at a
symposium
after his speech a participant privately
discusses with him his inventions he
asks robert how he managed to invent a
tough skin despite human skin being
naturally soft then deduces that robert
used transgenesis on human genes
violating bioethics in his defense
robert states that he only does the
experiment as his personal project and
it is only tested on mice
however the scientific community forces
him to discontinue his research
resulting in him laying off his servants
at home except for marilia
robert goes home and watches vera who is
reading a book closely through camera
footage
he enters her room and she asks him what
he is going to do to her he replies that
he does not know vera reminds him that
she belongs to him but robert
inconveniently slips out of her room
marilia warns robert that vera will kill
herself but he refuses to believe it
because he sees vera as a strong
survivor
while robert is away from home a man in
a tiger costume knocks on his front door
he turns out to be zekka morelia's son
she has not seen in 10 years
turns out he just robbed a jewelry store
and demands her to hide him in robert's
mansion for a few days and also asks
that robert performs surgery to change
his face which morelia refuses he sees
camera footage of veera's room and
deduces that she is her but marilia
denies it and warns him to go away and
leave her
he refuses ties and gags marilia and
searches for the keys to vera's room
vera almost escapes when he opens the
door but zekka quickly catches her she
tells him that if he kidnaps her robert
will be willing to do anything he says
robert arrives home to find morelia tide
and zekka on top of vera then he shoots
seca dead
while robert dumps zekka's body morelia
admits to vera that robert and zekka are
actually brothers but they do not know
it they were born from different fathers
zekka from another servant and robert
from mr ledgert her master as she had
served the legered family since a long
time ago robert was adopted by the
legend family and went into medical
school while zekka grew up on the street
and transported drugs
zekka earlier mistook vera for gal
robert's late wife because they share
some similarities
years ago zekka and gal had an affair
and were involved in a car crash that
burned gal badly and almost killed her
but zekka survived and ran away
robert later found her wife and did
everything he could do to keep her alive
but one day she looked at her reflection
in the windows and was shocked to see
her in humane form then jumped out of
the window killing her her daughter
norma was devastated seeing her mother's
suicide and developed an unstable mental
condition
after getting rid of zekka's body robert
sleeps beside vera and dreams of a
wedding six years ago when he saw that
norma had begun to socialize and heal
from her trauma however she was nowhere
to be found during the dance so he
looked for her
he found her unconscious in the garden
with her things thrown away
she woke up shocked and screaming
apparently mistaking robert for her
attacker
meanwhile vera also dreams of a man
vicente who worked in his mother's
boutique
he teased his co-worker christina about
how she would look great in a flowery
dress but she refused to wear it
he then attended the same wedding party
as robert and norma
slowly he made his way to norma then
they sneaked out during the dance along
with her friends
they went to a garden but then he
started to harass her however the
wedding musician began to sing the same
song that norma sang just before her
mother jumped off the window triggering
her causing her to frantically bite his
hand
he slapped her unconscious and then left
robert noticed him leaving with a
motorbike while he was looking for norma
the next day he left to wander using his
motorbike without knowing that robert
was following him
at some point robert crashed into him
and drugged him unconscious then dragged
him to an abandoned basement where he
chained him
meanwhile his mother went to the police
to receive news that his motorbike was
found but no sign of his body leaving
them to assume he was dead with the body
dumped into the sea
she was convinced her son would still be
alive and that the police should be
looking harder for him
robert visited norma in a psychiatric
hospital as her mind was rather
disturbed after the wedding party but
she did not want to meet him the doctor
even said that her condition got worse
when he visited her because she
identified him as her attacker
robert visited chain vicente and gave
him food and water
days later norma successfully attempted
suicide in the same manner as her
mother's leaving robert devastated he
gave vicente a shave and drugged him
unconscious again to perform a procedure
on him
then with the help of his team he gave
him a vaginoplasty procedure to change
his sex and over the course of years
changed his appearance to replicate his
late wife
once vicente asked why he would do this
to him because he did not feel like
committing any wrongdoings
robert explained that he is the father
of norma the girl he harassed at one
wedding party after a series of
procedures robert gave him a new name
vera the procedures clearly affected
vicente's sanity causing him to slit his
throat once but he still survived thanks
to robert's skillful hands
years later marilia arrived back at
robert's mansion because she had not
been there when norma tragically died
she asked about vera to which robert
replied that she was only a patient
staying with him to cope with his
depression vera started writing
repetitive numbers and words on the wall
and practiced yoga back to the present
day marilia clearly states her distrust
avira taking care of robert before she
goes back to her room
vera and robert promise each other that
vera would not be locked up anymore and
that she would not leave robert she then
leaves with morelia to go shopping while
robert receives a guest full hencio his
old co-worker he politely asks about how
robert is doing to which he replies that
he does not feel like performing
surgeries anymore but refuses to rent
his clinic to fulgencio
he then expels fulgencio away but he
insists on delivering one last piece of
news
he produces a newspaper reporting
missing persons cases including vicentes
with his photograph on the paper
he explains that vicente's mother is
still desperately searching for him
robert refuses to give any comments but
fulgencio deduces by himself that
vicente was kidnapped and robert gave
him an unwilling sex change procedure
and his consent papers were falsified
furthermore he also guesses that the
transgenesis skin research robert
conducted used vicente as his subjects
not mice
suddenly vera shows up returning from
her shopping and admits to fulgencio
that she underwent the procedure
willingly
puzzled fulgencio leaves the mansion
at night robert and vera are about to
have sexual intercourse but she admits
not feeling comfortable
however she remembered buying a
lubricant before and goes out of the bed
to search for it
she realizes it is not in her room then
heads down stairs to find it among her
newly purchased items
on robert's desk she bumps into
fulgencio's newspaper which clearly
shows vicente's photograph
after thinking for a while she retrieves
robert's gun from his desk drawer and
then goes back to the bedroom
she shoots robert dead and the noise
awakens marilia taking her gun as a
defense marilia tries to examine the
source of the noise but vera replies
that it was nothing and that she should
go back to bed
not trusting her morelia bursts into the
bedroom to find robert dead then
searches the room for a sign of vera
vera hiding under the bed takes her
chance to also shoot marilia dead then
escapes from the mansion
vera takes a taxi to her mother's
boutique saying hello to christina and
her mother who do not recognize her she
tearfully explains her story to
christina even mentioning the flowery
dress that she would like christina to
wear years ago before he disappeared
christina cannot believe vera is vicente
but vera explicitly admits that she is
vicente in front of her mother
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching